now Kate Forbes doesn't do interviews on
Sundays for religious reasons usually it
would be no big deal to pre-record an
interview with a politician but when it
comes to the s p it turns out that two
days really is an awfully long time in
politics because since our interview the
head of communications quit after
unwittingly giving out false information
about s p membership numbers and now the
party's chief executive Peter Murrell
has also resigned after taking
responsibility for the fias gate now Mr
Murrell by the way also happens to be
Nicola sturgeon's husband so that's all
worth bearing in mind when you listen to
this interview with Kate Forbes we
started by talking about independence
I think that's the Democratic approach I
think too much in our political debate
right now is vitriolic it's abusive it's
disrespectful and actually when it comes
to the SMP if we want to win
independence it comes down to respecting
our fellow citizens and the reasons why
they haven't yet been persuaded I think
many in the SMP are surprised that there
hasn't been a more substantial shift of
support for Independence not least when
we've seen a conservative government
attack Devolution where in the throes of
a Tory cost of living crisis and so on
and I think for me as leader it's about
reaching out beyond the divides reaching
out to people who haven't yet been
persuaded and making the case for how
Scotland can be wealthier and fairer you
know in the in the context of a
leadership contest it's easy to forget
that there's a lot more than that unites
us than divides us not least wanting to
eradicate poverty wanting to see a
growing prosperous economy wanting to
ensure that people aren't fuel poor I
think the path to that is good
governance and ultimately putting the
powers around Scotland's future into the
hands of those in Scotland
I talked about good governance and you
write a joint letter with Ash Regan
calling for information about the
current membership status of the SMP
what exactly are your concerns about
this process
well I have no concerns about the
process so I have full confidence in in
the Integrity of the election contest
all three candidates in fact were asking
for SMP membership figures because it
stands to reason that in any election
the candidates should know the size of
the electorate the size of the uh the
group of people that they're trying to
persuade and I'm very relieved that
those figures have now been confirmed
but I think those figures demonstrate
that continuity won't cut it my whole
pitch has been around building on the
smp's track record but re-earning the
trust of our SMP voters as well as the
wider public and the fact that we'd lost
so many members in such a short period
of time I think demonstrates that we do
need to shift focus and deliver change
continuity won't cut it who is the
continuity candidate
well I think if you were to ask the
other candidates and at least one has a
quite happily and readily accepted that
he is the the continuity candidate and I
have great respect for his approach But
ultimately there is a profound Choice
facing SMP members because I offer a new
approach I want to put our economy front
and center I want to reach out to no
voters as I've already said and I want
to ensure that we eradicate poverty and
rebuild the strength of the trust that
we enjoy with the Scottish people that's
how the SNP has won multiple elections
over the last 16 years and if we want to
continue to win elections then I believe
that we are at a Crossroads and we need
to take the approach that will
ultimately ensure we maintain that trust
going forward so you say that you've got
confidence in the process Ash Regan told
me last week who's obviously another of
the candidates that she thinks that
there's a conflict of interest with
Nicholas sturgeon's husband remaining as
SNP chief executive while the contest is
ongoing do you agree with that
no I don't because I think that we have
obviously the the third party electronic
provider of voting and and also because
I have full confidence in the process
ultimately this will be determined by
SMP members and I think there would be
outrage from the SMP members if there
was any perception of a lack of
Integrity so I think steps have been
taken in order to ensure the Integrity
of the process and I'm certainly
confident that whoever is elected will
be the person who SMP members have
chosen
now after her resignation Nicholas
sturgeon said Scotland is a progressive
country and the views of the next first
Minister therefore matter do you
consider yourself to have Progressive
views
I do indeed I think we live in a
pluralistic tolerant society which
allows space for everyone and of course
the definition of progressivity is that
we stand up for those who have no voice
and ensure that we are representing
their interest in Scotland today there
are extraordinarily deep social economic
inequalities with one in four children
in poverty with the life expectancy
between those in the most deprived and
the least deprived areas far too wide
and I focused during my campaign in not
just meeting with those who perhaps have
a vote but meeting for example with
women from ethnic minority groups who
have gone through the Asylum Seeker
process and who truly have no voice and
Ukrainian refugees so I think Scotland
has made great strides we need to be a
welcoming tolerant country and my hope
is that there's place for everyone the
Scottish government committed by the end
of the year to have ended gay and trans
conversion therapy now in the debate
till Monday night on Sky News our
political editor Beth Rigby asks you six
times if you would ban conversion
therapy even if the individual consented
and you didn't exactly give a straight
answer to that now you've had a bit of
time to think what is the position on
that
yeah so I said in that debate and I'll
see again today that conversion therapy
is abhorrent uh we've been through a
process where many people have shared
their lived experiences and on a hugely
sensitive issue like this I think it's
important that it's those lived
experiences that inform the approach
that we take to the debate now I
understand that there are people who
will see that there's no non-coercive
approach to conversion therapy and I
certainly you know I'm not here to to to
argue with that I'm here to build on the
experiences that people have shared and
ensure that any approach we take to the
legislation it reflects those lived
experiences but it is a very very
sensitive issue and I do think it's
important that rather than give you sort
of quick sort of gotcha answers
um on a matter of such importance that
we do reflect on the consultation
responses and we ensure the leg
legislation bans such an abhorrent
practice
um now just finally there are three
people in the race but really it's kind
of two horses at the front yourself and
hanza Yusuf
do you think he'll make a good first
minister
I think he would yes I do think I think
he has great talents I think he's got an
ability to connect with anybody to to to
reach people he has obviously been one
of my colleagues for many years and I've
seen him in action and I think that
right now the people of the SMP have a
genuine choice to make and what I offer
is change building on our track record
bringing a level of competence and a
track record to my Approach and ensuring
that we do deliver economic Prosperity
as a means of eradicating poverty
would you serve in his cabinet if you
asked
well it's it's somewhat presumptuous to
assume I will be asked and but certainly
and I'd be happy to serve with him or to
serve under him